in seiner Rede gesagt dass wenn das wenn
die territoriale Integrität der
Russischen Föderation bedroht wäre wir
alle Mittel verwenden einsetzen würden
um unsere unser Land zu schützen das ist
kein bluffter das ist dangers das ist
sehr gefährlich es ist auch
rücksichtslos es ist eine
gefährliche Rückschlüsse rücksichtslose
nukleare Rhetorik das ist ja nichts
neues das hat er schon öfter so gemacht
der weiß ganz genau dass ein Atomkrieg
weder gekämpft werden sollte noch
gewonnen werden kann und Konsequenzen
für Russland hätte die
Nato hat ja insbesondere ihre Ostflanke
gestärkt um hier jeglichen
Fehleinschätzungen so vorzukommen ja er
hat ja Möglichkeiten das sagten sie ja
aber was würde denn die NATO tun wenn
Russland tatsächlich
einsetzen würde in der Ukraine
wir werden sicherstellen dass es in
Moskau keinerlei Missverständnis gibt
über unsere Einstellung zur Verwendung
von Atomwaffen wie wir dann reagieren
werden das oder würden das hängt
natürlich ab von der Lage das
allerwichtigste ist für uns dass wir
jetzt verhindern dass so etwas überhaupt
passiert deshalb haben wir auch sehr
klar kommuniziert gegenüber Russland das
ist dann wirklich Konsequenzen ohne
Gleichen geben würde denn ein solcher
Atomkrieg kann von Russland nicht
gewonnen werden das haben wir ganz klar
gesagt und unsere Streitkräfte die
NATO-Streitkräfte sind
Einsatz zubereitet und das Bündnis steht
einsatzbereit und wir kommunizieren ganz
klar dass wir sehr aufmerksam beobachten
was Russland tut und bis jetzt haben wir
noch keine
änder Veränderungen gesehen in der
Ausstellung der
Atomstreit der Streitkraft lassen sie
mich zum Bereitschaft beiderseiten
zurückkommen wenn wir jetzt die Woche
noch mal anschauen und die letzten
Stunden wir sind ja hier in New York und
wir haben die 77
unvollversammlungen denken sie als NATO
denn auch daran eine außerordentliche
Sitzung zum Beispiel des
Sicherheitsrates der Vereinten Nationen
einzuberufen oder einen Sondersitzung
der NATO der der UNO Mitglieder
[Musik]
Putins ist eine Form der Eskalation
das ist aber keine Überraschung darauf
sind wir vorbereitet
wir werden ruhig bleiben und weiterhin
die Ukraine unterstützen
die Rede des Präsidenten Putin hat ja
ganz klar gezeigt dass der Krieg
offensichtlich nicht so läuft wie
Präsident Putin das geplant hat
er hat ja
sich ganz gehörig verrechnet er war ja
der Auffassung er könnte die Ukraine
innerhalb weniger Tage
erobern aber jetzt musste er sich aus
Nord aus der nordukraine zurückziehen
die Offensive in Don Bass wurde von den
ukrainischen Streitkräften gestoppt und
die Ukraine denen das ist es gelungen
erhebliche territorialgewinne wieder zu
verzeichnen das heißt jetzt findet die
teilmobilisierung der russischen
Streitkräfte statt und das zeigt uns
ganz deutlich dass er sich
offensichtlich
verrechnet hat und das ist der Grund
warum wir das jetzt auch tun muss lassen
Sie uns ein wenig über die
Einsatzbereitschaft der großen und die
Bereitschaft überhaupt der russischen zu
sprechen wie schätzen Sie die
Einberufung der 300.000 Reservisten ein
sind sie gut ausgebildet sind Sie in der
Lage überhaupt zu kämpfen haben sie die
Moral die Einstellung
gut da müssen wir uns erstmal das müssen
wir uns genau anschauen wir müssen sehr
vorsichtig sein wenn wir diese Zahlen
hören denn das diese 300.000 Reservisten
zu mobilisieren braucht dann seine Zeit
und wir wissen ganz genau dass die
russischen Streitkräfte wirklich
schlecht ausgerüstet sind und für diese
300.000 Reservisten braucht man
natürlich erstmal die richtige
Ausstattung das Material die Waffen und
so weiter und Sie brauchen die Logistik
aber der Einsatz von mehr Streitkräften
wird den Konflikt eskalieren das wird zu
weiteren Verlusten an Menschenleben
führen auf russischer und auf
ukrainischer Seite und
man muss natürlich gestoppt werden da
kann ich einfach ein anderes Land
erobern wollen und dort eine Inversion
stattfinden lassen das ist ein Verstoß
gegen das Völkerrecht und deshalb sind
ja auch Sanktionen gegen Russland
erlassen worden und wir müssen die
gesamte internationale
Völkergemeinschaft mobilisieren dass wir
ganz klar die russische Invasion den des
Nachbarlandes der Ukraine verurteilen
sie sprachen über Eskalation was ist
denn jetzt wie sehen sie wie schätzen
sie denn die Schwäche ein der russischen
Militärs wäre das ist zurückzuführen
sicherlich auf eine schlechtes
Urteilsvermögen auf eine
Fehleinschätzung der russischen
Streitkräfte und ihrer Möglichkeiten es
ist auch die ist auch ein Problem der
Moral der Truppe und Putin hat natürlich
ganz gewaltig die NATO und die
internationale Völkergemeinschaft
unterschätzt er hatte ja wohl angenommen
wir würden überhaupt nicht reagieren und
die Ukraine auch nicht unterstützen wie
wir es ja getan haben und auch weiter
tun werden
die NATO Verbündeten sind nicht Teil des
Konfliktes unterstützen indes die
Ukraine um der Ukraine zu helfen ihr
Selbstverteidigungsrecht auch zu üben
das ist ein Recht das in der Karte der
Vereinten Nationen fest verankert ist
und wir sind ja hier heute bei der bei
den Vereinten Nationen und man kann
die Unterstützung also der Ukraine gegen
den ergressor ist in 100%iger
Übereinstimmung mit allen dem
gut wenn wir jetzt die Folgen sehen die
militärischen aber auch die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen der sagt der
Sanktionen beispielsweise des Westens
sie sprachen ja in der Vergangenheit
über die Tatsache dass Natron das
Senator langsam Waffen
fehlen was muss jetzt die NATO tun um
ihr Waffenarsenal wieder aufzufüllen ihr
eigenes sprechen Sie beispielsweise mit
den Rüstungsfirmen oder haben sie andere
Notmaßnahmen
nein die NATO spricht ja nicht mit der
Rüstungsindustrie sondern wir sprechen
mit den Regierungen der NATO Verbündeten
und fordern die dann auf dafür zu sorgen
dass mehr Waffen zur Verfügung gestellt
werden mehr Munition wir müssen
natürlich unsere eigenen
Waffenarsenal alle weiter wieder
auffüllen und gleichzeitig die Ukraine
unterstützen weiter unterstützen in den
ersten Monaten des Krieges
die meiste kam ja die meiste
Unterstützung für die Ukraine in Form
von Waffen und Munition aus unseren
eigenen Beständen das ist natürlich
jetzt für alle NATO Verbündeten ist die
Lage so dass wir sehr die Waffen und
sehr viel Munition geliefert haben in
die Ukraine um die Ukrainer zu
unterstützen dadurch haben wir unsere
Bestände vermindert und wir brauchen wir
müssen diese Bestände wieder auffüllen
das tun wir derzeit das machen die
einzelnen NATO-Länder die Regierungen
der NATO Verbündeten und die sprechen
mit ihren ihrer Rüstungsindustrie wir
haben da ein spezielles eine spezielle
Zusammenarbeit auch mit Partnerländern
und
wir haben in Brüssel einen Dialog mit
den führenden Vertretern der
Rüstungsindustrie sie sprachen über die
russische Entschlossenheit die jetzt
offensichtlich etwas nachlässt wie ist
denn jetzt im Hinblick auf Europa und
die europäischen Regierungen wie sehen
Sie die Lage wenn jetzt ein harter
Winter auf uns zukommt
und wenn dann in Europa sie liefert also
Schwierigkeiten haben Gas und und Strom
genug zu haben gut die Europäer und
Europäerinnen zahlen ihren Preis für
diesen Krieg der Krieg hat für uns alle
Konsequenzen der Gaspreis ist in die
Höhe geschossen die Nahrungsmittel
werden immer teurer die Inflation ist
gestiegen aber die Alternative nämlich
der Ukraine nicht zu helfen würde
bedeuten dass wir einen sehr viel
höheren Preis würden zahlen müssen denn
in der Ukraine scheitert dann ist das
eine Lehre die erziehen muss aus dem
ganzen Konflikt und das nicht nur er so
auch andere
Regierungschefs und Diktatoren dass sie
nicht ganz einfach ein anderes Land
überfallen müssen das heißt die Ukraine
kämpft nicht nur für die eigene
Sicherheit sondern auch für unsere
Sicherheit wir zahlen dafür einen Preis
viele Menschen leiden unter den Folgen
aber wir müssen uns natürlich vor Augen
führen dass der Preis den wir zahlen in
Geld
gezählt in in Euros und Donners gibt's
zählt werden kann wobei sich die Opfer
der Ukrainer solche Menschenlebens
rechnen und deshalb müssen
sie sagen also dass die Unterstützung
der Europäischen Union nicht nach nicht
nachlassen wird
sehen Sie wir haben eine Bereitschaft
ohne Gleichen alle gemeinsam die Ukraine
zu unterstützen und jetzt sind wir auf
einen harten Winter vorbereitet der
Winter kommt er wird vielleicht hart
werden
aber wir dürfen natürlich in unseren
Bemühungen der Unterstützung der Ukraine
nicht nachlassen wir müssen sie weiter
unterstützen denn wir sehen ja die
Realität das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
eine für Putin schmerzhafte Art und
Weise
zu einer
friedlichen Lösung in der Ukraine auch
zu finden